nuclear experts from the international
atomic energy are on their way to
ukraine's giant saparicia facility
they're aiming to check the safety of
the russian-occupied plant which has
seen several near disasters in recent
weeks
russia installed
russian authorities rather in the nearby
town of eden
accused ukraine of drone strikes on the
power station but russia is accusing
shelling by the ukrainians
and ukrainian-held nikopol on the
opposite bank of the nipa river and
other areas near the plant including the
city of safarico
today the head of the iaea mission bravo
grossi said they were going ahead
despite reports of continued shelling
we are moving
we are aware of the current situation
there has been
increased military activity including
this morning um until very recently a
few minutes ago i have been briefed by
the ukrainian regional military uh
commander
here about that and the inherent risks
but weighing the pros and cons
and having come so far we are not
stopping
we are moving now we know that there is
a
an area as you know the so-called gray
zone where the last line of the
ukrainian defense comes and before the
first line of the russian
occupying forces begin
where the risks are significant
at the same time
we consider that we
have the minimum conditions to move
accepting that the risks are very very
high
dw correspondent matthias berlinger is
standing by for us in safarisia matthias
what more do we know about the un team's
mission today
yeah the hope is to arrive at the plant
today and to start their work what
they're going to do there is to
see the working conditions of the people
who are working there whether they can
work in conditions that ensure safety
with all the safety protocols are still
in place the uh
safety mechanisms still working whether
the fuel that has been stored there is
still there and things like that it's a
dangerous trip he has just said it
because they have to cross the line it's
the first time that the iaea has to
cross uh a front line in a war um and
there have been has been shelling this
morning and there have been warnings
that this might not go ahead we've just
heard uh seen the head of the military
administration here saying that the
mission might not be able to proceed we
don't know much about
much more now
and there are reports that this shelling
continues with i guess both sides again
blaming each other
yes that's what's happening there was
shelling again in the at the site uh in
and there has also been shelling at
least that's what the ukrainian side
says off the road there the uh shelling
the ukrainians accused the russians off
um of the gray zone that he has just
been speaking of how successful
can this mission
really be considering they do need time
and time is not on their side
so the hope is that the some of the
inspectors that have that are going
there now will stay there and will
continuously monitor the situation the
russians have in principle said that
they would agree to that and uh the iaea
has said that they want to do that that
would of course be crucial because um
in a day or two uh it's possible to just
clean up a few things and you know
present a picture and then
what happens after they leave is unclear
so staying there continuously monitoring
would probably uh enhance the
effectivity of this mission by a lot
but that would take commitment from both
the russians and the ukrainians in in
trying to find a joint solution here
wouldn't it
i think the ball is on the russian side
if the refresher agrees that they can
stay there they can stay there ukraine
doesn't have any influence on what's
happening on site um i think the most
important part from the ukrainian side
was to allow safe passage for them to
negotiate the route of passage to ensure
that nothing will happen to them on the
way that was the ukrainian part they
also gave them information about what
they should inspect their technical
details about the power plant but
whether they can stay on site is more a
decision that the russians have to make
dw's matthias burlinger many thanks
let's get more from former british army
officer and military analyst mike martin
how likely is russia to allow for an
extended monitoring mission in south
asia
i think russia's playing games at the
moment so your listeners
viewers might recall that at the
beginning there was a big argument about
whether the team was going to come
through kiev um
through the ukrainian side whether it's
going to come through russia the
russians lost that battle so now what
they're doing is playing games and
saying well you know you can only come
for a day or you've got to queue up like
everyone else at the checkpoints we
can't give you uh extended passes so
really it's just in the russians hands
we've also been reporting on ukraine's
counter-offensive in hassan for days now
about whether or not it will go ahead
and in what form what more can you tell
us about what's going on
um we don't want to go into too many
details for obvious reasons and the
ukrainians are
operating a very strict media blackout
but the offensive has started
and the phase that they're in at the
moment is what's called a shaping phase
and and what you do in a shaping phase
is you uh you take out infrastructure so
the ukrainians have hit a couple of
bridges over the last 48 hours
you continue to cut target air defense
command and control and supply
there's there's probably about 10 or 20
000 russian soldiers
in that pocket north of the dinipro
river it will be impossible to kill
every last one of them so what the
ukrainians are trying to do is shape the
battlefield
to create situations where they collapse
or run away but we shouldn't expect this
to be quick it's 10 000 russian soldiers
um but we will see this play out over
the next month or so
at the same time i think it's important
to
bring up uh these reports that uh we're
hearing of u.s intelligence officials
saying that russia's military is facing
severe manpower shortages but at the
same time there have been reports that
the kremlin is also assembling a third
army corps what can what can you tell us
there
well i i think there's two things we
have to look at here one is quantity of
soldiers and one is quality and russia
has suffered from a lack of both
throughout the war and you know they've
taken fairly substantial casualties as
well so the third army corps
they tried to assemble fifteen thousand
soldiers and they've managed to get
about five thousand and if we look at
the quality a lot of these guys are uh
they've extended the age limit to sixty
um there are reports of them offering
prisoners early release to go into it so
there will be about 5 000 very poorly
trained some reports say they're getting
two weeks uh soldiers i think the
russians are intending to position them
in the north of the country
to create a kind of a diversion or a
demonstration because it will mean that
ukraine will have to tie down some units
up in the north of the country but
really i think what this is is a a bit
of a distraction you know a little
annoyance that ukraine has to deal with
but it's not substantially going to
affect what is going on in the south in
herson and in crimea a question of
quality no quantity as you heard it
there from military analyst mike martin
thank you very much
thank you
you